hi everyone there are plenty of seats
down here if anyone wants to move
downstairs okay so welcome to today's
seminar as you well know biomedical
research has flourished in this country
due in a very large part to the
visionary establishment of both
intramural and extramural research
programs supported by the National
Institutes of Health every day now we
see and hear about newly acquired
information from labs large and small
working on understanding all aspects of
biology much of which has direct impact
on human health and well-being and often
from very unexpected in very unexpected
ways we are now in a period in which the
biomedical research and enterprise is
being squeezed by at least two forces
one caused by our own success in
attracting bright people to research
careers swelling the size of our
enterprise and one caused by
recessionary and political forces that
have resulted in reducing overall
research dollars available to support
these talented people as a research
scientist myself and now Dean of the
Graduate School I'm very happy to have
with us here today Jon Lorsch to talk
about his ideas for stabilizing the
biomedical research enterprise jon is
director of the National Institute of
General Medical Sciences which provides
a major portion of funding for basic
research in biological mechanisms in a
wide variety of model systems and also
provides the majority of funding for the
training of young scientists thus his
ideas and NIGMS
policies have a huge ripple effect on
all of science John moved to NIH to
almost 2 years ago from Johns Hopkins
University where he was a professor in
the biophysics and biophysical chemistry
department his research interests are in
structural analysis of the eukaryotic
translation machinery he moved his
research group to NIH meaning he's still
very much one of us facing the
challenges of maintaining a research
program
while also examining ways the NIH can
help us all do this better so please
join me in welcoming John here today
thank you
Thank You Lynn so my life you can hear
me good thank you very much for the
invitation to speak here it's been a
great visit so far I got to talk about
science yesterday and I'm going to talk
about science policy I want to talk
about some of the challenges that Lynn
alluded to and some ideas we have for
how we can meet those challenges so one
of the things I hope to convince you of
during the course of the talk is that
the future is actually not so grim and
that we really can if we work together
improve the efficiency and the
sustainability of the enterprise and
that the future actually is potentially
quite bright but again it's going to
take all of us working together to get
there since I'm at a medical school I'll
tell you that whatever rules you have I
have a hundred times more so you don't
have to worry so I know many of you are
familiar with NIGMS but let me just give
you a brief overview for those of you
who aren't the Institute has two
overarching missions the first is to
promote fundamental research on living
systems in order to lay the foundation
for advances in disease diagnosis
treatment and prevention and the second
mission which is actually related
closely the first is to enable the
development of the best trained most
innovative and productive biomedical
research workforce possible and I will
just highlight this phrase here lay the
foundation because that really is the
fundamental mission that and I GMS is
trying to achieve so the research we
support the training we promote are
really laying the foundations on which
the other 26 NIH institutes and centers
promote their missions their missions
that are focused on specific diseases or
specific organ systems okay now they say
you don't know an NIH Institute until
you know its budget so let me
tell you a little bit about our budget
the fiscal year 2015 budget was almost
two point three seven billion dollars
it's a little bit less than it was pre
sequester but I think you all agree it's
still a very significant amount of money
the way we disperse this money is that
about 90 percent of it goes to support
extramural research so that's research
conducted outside the walls of NIH at
medical schools universities other
research institutes across the country
close to nine or ten percent of the
budget goes to our training workforce
development diversity building mission
that's a little bit fuzzy because some
of the things going on out here in the
blue area and research are also related
to workforce development and training
but what you can see from this is that
we are on almost completely
outward-facing Institute we have only
one very small intramural program which
is a single postdoctoral research
training program that funds postdoctoral
fellows to work at NIH institutes and at
the FDA about 20 of them a year so again
we are almost completely outward-facing
focusing on supporting research
throughout the United States now one
thing I always like to say a very
important point is that that 2.3 seven
billion dollars I mentioned to you is
not monopoly money okay and this is
something I take extremely seriously
that two point three seven billion
dollar budget we have is hard-earned
taxpayer money and so it's absolutely
incumbent on on us to make sure that
that taxpayer money is being invested in
the best possible way so really our job
is to ensure that the taxpayers funds
are invested in fundamental biomedical
research in the most efficient and
effective ways possible that is to get
them the best returns the most and the
best science possible for their money
okay and that's something I think we all
need to keep in our minds at all times
whether you are the person by deciding
how the money is invested or you're the
recipients of that money so this year
just a few months ago
we released our five-year strategic plan
and I encourage you to go to our website
you don't have to write this whole thing
down you can just go to the NIGMS
website and find this but it lays out
the general themes goals and strategies
to accomplish these objectives and goals
that the Institute intends to pursue
over the next five years one of the
really key areas that we are focusing on
as part of the strategic plan is
reinvigorating our commitment to
investigator initiated research and so
you might say well why does NIGMS which
has historically been the home of
fundamental investigator initiated
research need to focus on reinvigorating
its commitment to that and the the data
behind that decision are shown here this
shows two different but related things
the blue bars which are this axis over
here show the funds that NIGMS had
committed to what you might call
programmatic research or specific
investments in certain scientific areas
in which the funds were set aside for
those scientific areas to be less
favorable you might call it top-down
research in which NIH in consultation
with members of the research community
decide to put aside a certain amount of
the budget and targeted at a specific
scientific area and you can see that in
the early 1990s over here and I GMS had
almost no money invested in this kind of
programmatic top-down research but
between 1998 or there abouts and 2003 or
so and actually for some years after
that over here you can see that that
amount of money grew dramatically and
1998 to 2003 corresponds to the doubling
of the NIH budget and so during that
time other uses for the amount of money
that was continually coming into the
system each year were found and it was
put into these kinds of targeted
scientific initiatives now the red line
which is the other axis the right-hand
axis over here
represents the percent of NIGMS
research portfolio that was dedicated to
investigator-initiated research sort of
the reciprocal of these blue bars and
again you can see that in the early
1990s 99% of the institute's portfolio
was investigator-initiated research but
during the budget doubling and in the
years following it that percentage fell
to the level it was in 2013 when I
arrived at NIGMS of only 80 percent so
we went from 1% targeted research in our
portfolio to 20 percent in the course of
about a decade or so now we've concluded
that since the budget doubling has been
over for 15 years it really is necessary
at this point for us to shift this
balance to bring this red line back up
which is going to mean bringing these
blue bars down and that's something
we've been focusing on both in the short
term by making strategic decisions about
how we are distributing our portfolio
and what programs we are investing in
and keeping running and also in the long
term as we think about how best to
support science and the overall
enterprise that that we fund now another
way you can see the need for us to
refocus our efforts on
investigator-initiated research is to
look at what we call the success rate
for grants okay so this plot shows three
related things on this axis over here
are the number of research project grant
applications in the blue line that were
submitted to NIGMS research project
grants are grants to generally
individual or small teams of
investigators and what we're looking at
here is investigator-initiated grants
the lion's share of RPGs are made up of
ro1s which are the really
bread-and-butter of the biomedical
research enterprise so again the blue
lines are the applications we received
versus fiscal year the red lines are the
number of awards we made so the number
of grants we actually funded and then
the green line is what we call the
success rate this is the number of
grants we funded divided by the total of
number applications each year and so
what you can see is that this green line
started out
at the end of the budget doubling nearly
40% so nearly 40% of the applications we
received in a year were being funded at
the end of the budget doubling this
began to fall as the doubling receded to
the point where in 2013 I arrived at a
GMS it had fallen to a historic low of
20% okay so it had almost been cut in
half over that period of ten years we
predicted based on modeling and expected
levels of grants or applications that if
we didn't make any changes to our
portfolio it was going to stay stagnant
at 20% and so a variety of changes in
our portfolio we made for instance we
reduced the number of funding
opportunity announcements targeted
specific scientific areas that we had
out we reduced the budgets of the large
centers that we supported longer term
we've made decision to close some large
initiatives that have been ongoing since
the beginning of the budget doubling and
we did see some improvement this year so
rather than him being stagnant of 20%
the success rate actually rose to 25%
now so that's positive news to be sure
but just two points about it one is it's
critical as we move forward and continue
to think about how we distribute our
funds and manage our portfolio that we
keep this success rate at least this
high if not increase it further rather
than let this be a spike of a single
year followed by a return to these poor
success rates the other point I'll make
though is I don't view this twenty five
percent success rate as good enough yet
I think we really need to continue to
work on this to make sure that all the
outstanding or as many outstanding
investigators as we can who are
struggling to get support are able to
conduct and continue their research so
those are two things that we'll be
working on over the coming years now
that's just an introduction to some of
the directions we're heading globally
and I can I encourage you to go look at
our strategic plan to find out more
details and more of our thinking about
other areas but people frequently ask me
what I do all day long
and what I do all day long in addition
to going to a lot of meetings is to
think about very hard problems and
that's one of the appeals for me for
this job and one of the reasons I took
it I get to think about very important
very hard problems that if we could
solve would really make a big positive
impact on the research enterprise and I
won't go through all of these here but
these show some of the hard problems
that I spend my time thinking about
they're things like the distribution of
funding among investigators the academic
business model how the scientific reward
system feeds into both productive and
unproductive parts of the enterprise and
issues related to the workforce and
training and how many people we can
support and are we adequately training
them for example but what I realized as
I thought about all these very hard
problems is there was really one central
problem that fed into all these other
hard problems in different ways okay
that influenced each of these hard
problems in one way or another and I
determined at least I thought that if we
couldn't solve that central hard problem
we were gonna have a very hard time
making a significant impact on these
other hard problems and that central
hard problem in my view is how we
support Fundamental Research so as many
of you know the way we fund some
fundamental research right now largely
through the ro1 mechanism that I
mentioned a minute ago
is a project-based funding model so we
asked researchers to decide what they're
doing in their lab and to break that up
their projects the research in their lab
up into specific projects and then
predict four or five years in advance
exactly what they're gonna be working on
right down to here the experiments I'm
going to do over the next four or five
years here are even the controls I think
I'm gonna do and we let them break their
research up as much as they are creative
enough to do and apply for as many
grants as they can write in terms of
those projects they've now broken their
research up into now many people myself
included think that this project based
funding system
creates a number of inefficiencies in
the enterprise
I'm not going to enumerate them all but
let me just tell you to in my view the
first is that this is not how science
actually works right at least not the
best science right if you can tell me
exactly the experiments you're gonna do
over the next four years I think they're
probably not worth doing okay the best
science is when you're following your
nose and you find something interesting
and you go off in that direction and and
Enrique gets a new idea when he's in the
shower right and it goes into lab and
makes us students change directions
right that's when the big exciting stuff
tends to happen okay and here we're
constraining this we're putting a
constraint on how science actually works
and we're trying to fit a round peg into
a square hole or vice versa because
that's one problem doesn't reflect how
the best science actually happens the
other problem is related to this this
hard problem distribution of funding as
I mentioned because we let people break
their research up into as many different
individual projects or grants as they
are creative enough to subdivide and get
as many of those as they are able to
convince study sections to give them
we've created a very skewed distribution
of funding in the biomedical research
enterprise and let me just show you that
for a second okay so here what we've
done is we've taken NIGMS grantees so
these are people that have at least one
NIGMS grant and we've counted the amount
of NIH total direct costs each one has
okay so this isn't counting HHMI or
anything else this is just NIH funding
and then we've put them in bins based on
the top part of that funding
distribution so this is the people who
have up to 185-thousand direct cost up
to 210 up to 320 etc okay and so you can
see what the distribution of our
portfolio looks like now the red line is
the average number of NIH grants that
each one of that the investigators in
each of those bins has so it goes from 1
all the way up to about four and a half
okay now if you analyze this in a
slightly different way what you find is
that 5% of our grantees
have 25% of the NIH funds that our
grantees have and 20% of them have a
half okay well maybe that's weird
NIGMS thing but if you look at the
entire NIH portfolio it's exactly the
same distribution okay now that's a
pretty skewed long-tailed distribution
there was an article in The New York
Times about a year ago talking about
Medicare or reimbursement to doctors and
physicians and how skewed it was and how
big a problem this was going to become
and it was exactly the same skew five
percent get a quarter twenty percent get
a half so if it's a problem there I
think I can make an argument that it's
not the most efficient thing here now
you say well okay how much money if you
if you could recover some of that money
how much would it really put back in the
system to help fund new investigators to
help keep really productive excellent
labs open and if you just count the
NIGMS direct costs that the people who
have over half a million dollars a year
and NIH costs have it's almost four
hundred million dollars okay so even if
I could only recover ten percent of that
money that would still be 40 million
dollars I could put back into our
funding system okay so I'm not talking
about insignificant tweaking the edges
there really is significant improvements
in the distribution that could be done
to help young investigators to help
outstanding labs that are trying to get
by on you know single grant with five
people in the lab now counter-argument
to this always says well the people that
have that great amount of money the 5%
they have they're the 5% because they're
the best scientists and they're getting
us the most for the money they're making
the big discoveries they're publishing
all the papers it turns out and try to
be as data-driven as I can in thinking
about these things it turns out that we
have an increasing body of evidence that
indicates that that is not true at least
not on average okay so this was an
analysis that was done in 2010 led by
Jeremy Berg when he was director of
NIGMS and what it shows is in red the
number of publications that arose from a
grant during the grant period as a
function of total annual NIH direct
costs of the grantees it's the average
or the average impact factor of the
journal in which that group published
papers okay that's you know both of
these are flawed metrics someone could
publish one paper that's much more
important than someone else's ten papers
but we're talking about averages here so
some of those things get buffered out
okay
what you see and these these are the
interquartile ranges these bars so you
can see there's a big range okay that's
true but what's really striking to me
about this curve is okay in the
beginning part of the curve it goes up
very rapidly as you'd expect if you have
no money you're not doing much but when
you get to somewhere and that's a
$300,000 range of direct cost a year
when you go above that you start to see
although it does increase productivity
in terms of papers or in terms of the
impact factor the curve the slope is
very shallow which is diminishing
returns okay you are not getting a unit
increase in productivity or impact for a
unit increase in funding levels and so
what was one thing striking and these
data was that once you got above about
700 $750,000 the actual net amount of
productivity that was coming out of
these things was actually decreasing
okay and then all kinds of reasons for
this to me it comes down to bandwidth
okay if you're focusing on you know the
stuff in your lab that's the core and
what you're most excited about you're
going to be be able to put more
bandwidth into that you're gonna be able
to mentor the students you're gonna come
up with more ideas as you subdivide that
more and more right that's gonna get
come down the amount of ideas you have
the amount of time you have to put into
it the amount of time you have to mentor
is going to decrease and of course the
amount of time you have to spend trying
to keep this enterprise funded is going
to go up and up which is time taking
away from doing the actual research and
mentoring and training okay now I do a
simple back of the envelope calculation
to make this point
a little more
my job fundamentally is to act as an
investor of the taxpayers money okay I'm
trying to optimize the returns in terms
of as I said great science the amount
and the quality that we get for the
amount of money that Congress decides to
give us whatever that is and you can do
using these averages a calculation we
say okay well I have a choice and I'm
frequently faced with this choice in any
given council round one grant
application came in it's from an
established P I it got a great score L
say it got a 5 percentile it's to get
the established P I who now has
currently has to are once and getting
400,000 direct cost a third are one so
they're gonna go from $400,000 here to
$600,000 here if we give them the grand
that's actually gonna buy the taxpayer
on average one more paper a year okay
now that's an average okay there are
people who can really do better and beat
the curve but note that although there
are people who can do better and beat
the curve there are by the same token
people who do worse who aren't getting
funded because that's what I was showing
you here okay so that's one the other is
a new investigator okay she's coming in
for her first grant it'll be the only
funding she had she's gonna go from
essentially zero to say two hundred
thousand that's gonna by the taxpayers
on average five papers so the difference
is four papers again okay I'm talking
averages there's all kinds of caveats
here but from an investment point of
view which one's the better bet okay so
that's kind of thinking that I'm trying
to do another way of putting this is
what should our funding metric be what
should our measure of how we are funding
science be currently it's the number of
grants we give okay we say how many
grants we give what's the success rate
of grant applications that denominator
being the applications the numerator
being the number of funded grants but
another way another way to think about
this what we should be focusing on is
how many investigators are we supporting
okay now that when I first said
often sounds trivial well okay you're
shifting from grants to investigators
but it really is not trivial it's a
different focus right we're now trying
to say what we the NIH wants to do is to
maximize productivity and impact by
focusing on how many investigators were
going to support at sustainable levels
okay rather than just throwing it open
and saying here's grants go get them and
seeing how many people can you know
scurry up four or five grants okay it
really is a different focus and it's
something that we not just another GMS
but nih-wide are talking about should
this be more of the thing that we're
focusing on okay so this kind of
thinking has led us to start an
experiment which I want to tell you
about now it's called the maximizing
investigators research award and I'll
tell you the details in a second the
overall idea is to switch from a model
in which we are funding projects and
letting people get as many grants as
they can for their projects to one in
which we are supporting research
programs okay
which would be a single grant to support
the work in your lab much more flexible
as I'll tell you hopefully more
sustainable more secure but once you
have that grant
that's your NIGMS research funding and
we're not going to give you any more at
least for that five-year period okay now
what do we think the advantages of this
mechanism are before I go through the
details and we think there are a number
of potential advantages to this the
first is to increase the stability of
funding I'll show you how we're going to
do that but we think that if we can
increase the stability of funding we
will actually get better science from
people because they will be willing to
take on more ambitious projects and
approach them more creatively flipping
this around I think many people agree
that the instability of funding the
constant worry that you're gonna fall
off the funding cliff and be unfunded or
have to lay off half your lab makes
people conservative makes people
conservative and the science they
propose and they attempt and it makes
study sections conservative in the
science they fund so that's one man the
second is to increase flexibility for
investigators to let them
their noses like I said and change
directions as new opportunities arise as
Enrique has new ideas in the shower
right his labs cringing right now but
you know we want to give them that
flexibility the classic example I like
to give for why this is important is RNA
I okay
RNA I came from a failed control
experiment right they did a control
experiment they saw they were doing
anti-sense RNA they put in the sense
strand and it worked just as well as the
anti sent strand right now could have
ignored this said no that's weird
something strange is going on luckily
Andy fire had the courage in fact the
resources because he was at the Carnegie
Institute and the freedom to follow this
because he wasn't tied to specific games
and he did and hence RNA I was
discovered that we have this amazing new
understanding of a central biological
process and this amazing new technology
what I worry about don't know the answer
but I want to worry about is how many
amazing discoveries have not been made
because when the graduate student of the
postdoc went to the PI and said look at
this weird result this weird control the
P I said that is kind of weird
but I've got to renew this grant at 18
months so you got to get back to the
specific aims because otherwise we're
doomed
right I don't know the answer but I
suspect more than a few great
discoveries remain unmade because of
that as I mentioned we also want to
improve the distribution of funding okay
now we recognize there still needs to be
arranged that some people really can
efficiently use more money than the
average but we need to get to a
situation that is optimized relative to
where we are that distribution I showed
you and one of the reasons is because we
have no idea where the next big
discovery is going to come from just
like that RNA i case and we know from
looking back at the history of science
that discoveries come from all kinds of
strange and unexpected places
many of them are made at Yale but many
of them are not made at Yale all right
they can be made all over by all kinds
of people studying all kinds of strange
unusual organisms for example again
going to my invest
stur analogy if you're investing in the
stock market and you only invest in the
blue chip stocks you're gonna get in
general a poor return than if you have a
distributed investment portfolio because
that maximizes the chances of the big
occasional payoff and also mitigates
your risks okay so that's I think
another core concept here we also want
to reduce the time investigators spend
writing grant applications right again
if you're trying to run a lab where you
are trying to keep yourself funded
either because you want three or four
laughs grants or just to keep that one
and you're writing multiple grants every
year that's time that you're not
spending thinking about the day-to-day
science and what's going to be really be
done next as opposed to trying to
predict in four years what you'll be
doing and it's time you're not mentoring
or teaching your students okay so I
think we really again could improve the
quality and maybe the amount of science
that came out of each unit lab if we
would free people's time up by reducing
the amount of grant writing they had to
do related to that we'd like to reduce
the amount of grants that have to be
reviewed okay people say to me wherever
I go
peer review is broken right you know
peer review is the problem you got a fix
peer review tweak it here do this you
know change 12 pages in the off 25 peer
review is not broken okay
peer review is just being asked to do
something it cannot do right what peer
review can do well is it can put things
into bins it can say here's promising
stuff you know this looks really
promising here's maybe you know maybe
promising not quite as much here's the
next year maybe there's a fourth tier
all right but the notion that we can
rank grants that I can say this grant on
Drosophila eye development is ranked you
know is actually more predictably more
likely to give a great result than this
grant on C elegans ovary development you
know which got a 5th percentile instead
of a first percentile not only does it
just intellectually not really work we
now have an increasing body of data that
it's not true
okay so the best thing we could do for
peer review the way we could fix quote
uncle peer review is to reduce the
number of applications they're being
asked to deal with to let them do what
they can do which again is you know make
broader distinctions and to increase the
success rate right if the success rate
is let's just say 50 percent that's a
whole different world than if the
success rate is 15 percent
all right okay so those are some of the
things we hope to achieve
so the program again is mirror
maximizing investigators research Awards
it's an experiment it's hopefully
experiment that's going to be expanding
my goal would be to expand it rapidly if
it begins to work well let me tell you
about what it's gonna look like it's
gonna be a single research grant for pi4
NIGMS it's going to use a new mechanism
called an R 35 they will because it's
gonna be a single grant on average be
bigger than what we currently give right
we want to give you enough money so you
can do your research we want to get you
in the sweet spot okay so whatever
that's gonna be based on our budget etc
and it's gonna be a year longer than our
current ro1 so currently four years is
the average our 100 GMS using me five
years there's gonna be a range of direct
costs as I said some people are going to
be able to convince the study sections
that they really can use more than the
median amount of money efficiently and
get you know a unit increase in
productivity at least but the range is
gonna be from something small to
$750,000 that's gonna be the cow okay
not to get us based on the data I showed
you is basically what we think that's
the most money that NIGMS should be
investing in anyone very few in terms of
research very few people will get that
much money but that is gonna be the
limit
they're not going to be tied to specific
aims in fact the grants don't have
specific aims instead the review is
going to be based really on two things
one is retrospective what did you do in
the last period of time whether that
five years or ten years okay that's
actually turns out to be one of the
better predictors for these established
investigators of what they're going to
do in the future the other will be just
lay out broadly what this area is you're
working on what you think the key
questions are and what you think the
strategies are for approaching them okay
you gotta have something some vision
that we assess but you're not gonna be
tied to that so if your postdoc finds
something unusual in a control
experiment in year 1.5 and that sends
you off in a new direction
that is perfectly fine in fact you're
not even gonna tell the study section
when you come in for renewal and I
should say these grants will be
renewable what the specific aims were
originally you're just gonna tell them
what you did and again
overall the questions that a pro and
strategies you think you're gonna follow
in terms of stability I mentioned that's
a key aspect of this we would like to
improve the stability of the system so
people aren't constantly popping in and
out of being funded and not being funded
are coming from two grants to one five
years versus four is one piece of that
that's you know maybe a minor thing but
an extra year I think from my point of
view is is a positive but maybe more
importantly we're going to be switching
from the current binary outcome of peer
review or you're either funded or you're
not right to one that's analog so that's
sounds sort of retro we're going from
digital to analog the idea though is
that we'll be able to modulate funding
levels based on peer review rather than
necessarily terminating your grant
so say you come into peer review now and
the study section says oh you did it was
great work it's pretty interesting stuff
that you're talking about doing but
you're not the top one or two grants in
my pile so you got a you know 37 or
something like that it's still a great
score chances are now you're not getting
funded at all in this new model what
we're going to do is have the ability to
say okay look they're saying you weren't
operating at the $400,000 our direct
cost level that you were at but rather
than just terminate your program we're
just going to ramp you
to something else okay so you keep going
you have to downsize a little bit but
you're not finished you can keep your
program moving okay I think that really
will allow us a lot more flexibility and
ability to keep the system stabilized
and currently the on/off system that we
have now I was determined when we were
writing coming up with this idea that I
wanted to let new and early stage
investigators into this program from the
start there was a lot of debate should
we make them do our ones first and then
let them come in and one of the good
things about my job is I could
occasionally make an executive decision
so this is one I made we are going to
let new and early stage investigators
straight into this system but the
pushback is always well you're basing
this on track record in large part
that's going to disadvantage young
investigators and of course it would if
we were comparing them to the
established investigators in the same
panel so what we're doing is we're going
to have distinct separate panels for the
established investigators and the young
investigators and different criteria
modified criteria for the young
investigators okay so in some ways
that's even better than the current
system because they're not going to be
in the same study section and they're
going to be judged in separate hopefully
improved ways now sometimes it's useful
to say to define something by what it's
not so I do want to make a couple things
clear but what mirror is not so Mira is
not targeted specifically at high-risk
high-reward research so this isn't the
Pioneer program the Pioneer Award for
one thing this is renewable this is
hopefully going to be a sustainable
system we do hope that the benefits I
told you about will empower people to do
more ambitious and more creative
research but we're not targeting it just
at you know you've got some crazy
high-risk idea we want this to be for
all the great science that NIGMS
traditionally funds and by the same
token it's not targeted specifically at
a perceived highly lead group okay so we
are not creating HHMI here although
we're using some of the I think you know
beneficial
specs of that kind of person or program
based funding again if this pilot
experiment works the idea would be to
expand it to be able to fund the entire
portfolio of NIGMS investigators okay
all of whom are excellent at least in my
view now what's the initial
implementation plan gonna be and here's
where the rub starts because we can't as
much as I would love to just say
everyone come in right now
you know the pool is open and the reason
is because a we don't know if that's
gonna work so you know if there's some
problem we don't want to throw
everything into one system and then find
out there's a problem most importantly
we have to pilot the peer review system
because everyone agrees that this is
going to rise or fall on how peer review
works and the peer review really has to
be very different than the current ro1
peer review in any ways it's got to be
orthogonal to it
so we can't just let the CSR ro1 study
sections start reviewing these right
next to our ones because they're going
to review them like our ones and we
can't have that okay so we really have
to break the mold the peer review in
many ways start a separate system and
try to make it work for what we're
trying to accomplish here and to do that
we need a moderate number of
applications so we can test these
procedures and so we've already issued
the first fo a and the first day way is
for established pis and in order to get
a small enough test group we had to put
some constraints in it so the
constraints are that they either have
two or more NIGMS are ones already or
one that's for over 400,000 indirect
cost so this immediately sounds like
you're creating the elite group okay but
remember that we are actually going to
be asking these people to trade some
amount of their direct costs on average
for the benefits of the system and put
that money back into the system to you
know improve the number of labs we can
support of the quality of support we
give them okay so the trade-off they're
going to lose a little bit of direct
costs in exchange for all these benefits
extra year
cetera now the second one which we are
writing and is now going through the
approval process is for new
investigators who are at an early stage
of their careers as I said I was
determined to let them in and again
we're gonna have separate review panels
and criteria for them if these start to
look like they're successful it is if
people apply for it if no one goes to
Tahiti instead of doing their research
and you know continues to be productive
we are going to expand this as fast as
we can the goal would be to open it to
everyone as soon as possible
but we really want to make sure we have
the peer review process worked out as
well as we can first okay now I wanted
to since I talked about new
investigators just talk briefly about
some new data we have concerning new
investigators and early stage
investigators because that's an area I'm
very concerned about is getting these
great scientists into the system funding
system as soon as we can to you know get
their labs off the ground to get them
producing and then keep it sustained
okay because if we lose a generation of
scientists because we're not focusing on
this it's really going to be a detriment
to the country now one of the ways NIH
has tried to support young investigators
getting into the system is by mandating
that every Institute and center is
supposed to keep the success rate for
grants to new investigators at least as
good as the success rates for new grants
to established investigators so new
grants to establish investigators and
these are NIGMS data ESI is our early
stage investigators young investigators
and then the red bars are the
experienced pis and you can see that
over the last five years and i GMS has
been successful in keeping the success
rate above the success rate for new
grants for experienced pis but note that
the success rate for new grants for
experienced pis is actually not very
high okay and so one question I do have
and I'm wrestling with is whether this
is the right bar as I'll show in just a
second the success rate for renewing a
grant for an established PA is
dramatically higher than this
okay so we've set the bar pretty low and
we're saying it has to be at least as
good as the hardest thing you know that
you can do and I wonder if maybe we need
something a little bit better than that
but another area we've been concerned
about is the first renewal so
investigate we're already giving new
investigators early stage investigators
some break maybe it's not enough of a
break
we give us some break we get them into
the system and then we've been worried
about what happens to them when they
come up for their first renewal because
anecdotally this has been said to be
really the stage at which they rise or
fall okay and it's very hard to get that
first renewal so one of my program
director Stefan Maas has been taking a
deep dive into the literature into our
data looking at this and so let me just
show you what we have here on the left
over here is the percent of projects for
all renewals of established investigator
so these are renewals of a new grant or
renewals of a grant that's in its you
know fifth renewal cycle all four
established investigators in green are
the grants that got funded or what we
call paid in red are the grants that
were submitted for renewal but not
funded and in blue are grants that never
came in for renewal at all there was no
application okay in yellow this yellow
dot shows the success rate because the
success rate is just the total number of
applications on the denominator and
those that were funded in the numerator
not taking into account all the ones
that never came in at all okay and so
you can see the success rate overall for
all renewals for established pis is very
high okay and it actually gets higher
with each renewal cycle up to the third
when you will cycle so the first one is
a little bit harder than a second the
third is the easiest there after Stefan
then broke that down into renewals of
new projects by established
investigators so he took out just the
first renewals of new grants going to
established investigators and he
compared that to renewals of new
projects from new investigators that is
their first renewal of their
and what he found was that overall this
the renewal rate is just just the
percentage of projects that get renewed
was higher for new investigators than
for established new vestigators renewing
a new grant so that seemed good because
that means that you know they're getting
renewed more often than a new grant to
an established investigator but when we
looked at it you know a little more
closely you realize that in fact if you
compare the red and the green bars the
success rate again the yellow dot is
actually higher for renewing new grants
for established investigators than
renewing new grants for new
investigators it's not dramatically
higher but it's a little bit higher and
so that's consistent with the lore that
it's hard to get that first renewal and
that certainly concerns us and so an
area that we want to focus on is this
first renewal and how can we make sure
that you know great new investigators
are making it through this really
critical stage of the first renewal but
another weird thing that you'll note in
this I'll talk about more in a second is
that this blue bar for established
investigators is much bigger than the
blue bar for new investigators so almost
40 are actually 45% close to 50% of new
projects funded for established
investigators never come in for renewal
they just walk away from them for one
reason or another and that's something
that we're interested in now excuse me
discuss more in just a second
but another thing that Stephane did was
to look at how the renewal rate compared
to the initial score of that first
application so we're looking at new
grants either for establish PI's or new
PI's okay and he looked at the
percentile score that that grant got
when it was initially funded and then
compared that or been that for the
renewal rate when it came in for a new
one okay and so on the left now are the
new investigators and on the right are
the established and if you follow the
green bar for the established you see
that it goes down
as the original grants percentile score
gets worse that's what you'd expect
perhaps pray or you might think that
you'd get more successful projects from
the higher scoring applications perhaps
but if you compare the new investigators
bars you'll know the trend is not the
same in fact the renewal rate for new
investigators who are funded with grants
that got at or above the 20th percentile
and these were generally grants that we
were what we call reaching for right
they were above where we generally would
be funding and because there were new
investigators we reached for them
there's renewal rate is actually higher
than the renewal rate of the established
investigators and even about the same as
the renewal rate of the new
investigators who scored in the zero to
ninth percentile right so this really
supports the idea that we should be as
we are doing giving some benefit to new
investigators in their first grant when
we fund them because it appears that the
ones we reach for actually are doing
quite well
both relative to new investigators who
scored better and to establish the
investigators okay so that does support
that but again I want to address this
issue of the disparity between the
fraction of grants that never come in
for a renewal of a new grant for
established a new investigators in that
trend you can see here quite clearly now
one possibility was that these grants
that don't come in for a renewal don't
come in for a renewal on average because
they're not success as successful as the
ones that do and what this would then be
telling us is that almost half of the
new grants we give to establish P is
these are new grants not renewals
weren't very successful and that could
be because of bandwidth you know if
you're giving a P I their third grant
they don't have as much time to devote
to it and so this is you know something
I think we need to think about and I
will say that 60% of the established pis
in this pool who are getting new grants
have at least one other grant from us so
stefan broke each of these cohorts up
that i just showed you the new
investigators they established according
to whether they did not apply for
renewal so a t2 application is a renewal
of that new grant they applied for one
and then he further subdivided the ones
who applied for a renewal according to
those who didn't get funded and those
who did get funded and what he's looking
at here he's looked at it in about 16
different ways to measure productivity
and impact I'm just going to show you
two but he has again hun 16 probably
different ways of looking at it
this is looking at the number of
publications that came out of that grant
period divided by dollars so per million
dollars for each of these cohorts these
are boxplots the black line is the
median and then the top is the 75th
percentile on the bottom of the 25th and
the full range is shown here okay and
what you see is in fact according to
publications per unit dollars the lowest
cohort is the ones that didn't come in
for renewal at all it's lower than the
ones that did come in for renewal and
that's kind of what you'd expect if this
group was just not as successful so they
didn't come in for renewal and the best
overall look like the ones that were
actually funded which is somewhat
heartening okay now another way to look
at that is citations per million dollars
so this is citations for the papers that
came out of that grant period again
divided by dollars and he sees the same
trend which is that the lowest is the
ones that never came in for a Newell the
highest is the ones that did come in for
a renewal okay so this supports the idea
again that the reason on average that
these people are not renewing their
grants is because the projects were not
as successful and he's looked at other
measures of impact using various
Thompson Reuters thing using some
internal NIH measures we see the same
thing over and over again the other
thing that's striking is that when you
compare the new investigators impact or
productivity to the established
investigators it is always at least as
good in some cases it's better
okay so this again supports the notion
that it is a good investment to fund
grants first grants for new
investigators because they are doing at
least as well by all these different
metrics if not better than a new grant
yet another grant to established bi now
the very last thing I want to say before
I took some questions is I mentioned
that the other mission of NIGMS is
training and there are lots of important
things going on in the training arena
and I didn't want to short change that
by not saying anything about it
so let me just very quickly tell you
some of the important areas we're
thinking about in terms of Workforce
Development and training the first is
developing the optimal workforce and one
of the key areas we're focusing on there
is building diversity and I mean
diversity very broadly going back to my
investor analogy from scientific
questions two approaches to regions and
to the backgrounds of the people doing
the research and the reason that's so
important is because diversity improves
performance has been showed in many
different arenas that that's true and so
therefore that's something we are
focusing on through all these different
dimensions PhD education and I GMS funds
almost half of the t32 training slots
for graduate students and undergraduates
that NIH as a whole gives so we really
are the 800-pound training gorillas some
of the things we're really going to be
pushing on over the next five years are
to promote innovation and
experimentation to improve outcomes of
graduate education so I really want to
find ways to empower you the people
doing the training to think about how to
you know change it science has changed
dramatically in the last 15 years and I
think it's maybe time for us to start
exploring other models to improve how
we're training scientists in response to
this changing scientific landscape to do
that though we need to improve our
ability to evaluate how training is
working and to assess outcomes so that's
something we're gonna be focusing on
both at NIH and in partnership with you
and also on Career Development there's
an increasing recognition that many
people who get PhDs
are going to go into all kinds of
different diverse careers that utilize
their training in important ways and we
want to see if we can improve their
ability to do that and their value when
they get to those diverse careers
outside of the traditional academic
researcher position scientists education
is also important NIH wide and to NIGMS
we fund the MSTP program the medical
scientist training program that Yale has
one of two fund MD PhD students there
was recently an advisory committee to
the director report on physician
scientists education and one of the
things they indicated they would like to
see NIH and the community focus on is
complementary models to the MST program
okay they said we should maintain strong
support for MSD P but we should also
think about alternative complementary
models that might be more efficient or
more effective for certain groups of
people overall one of the key issues as
I'm sure you know is retention in
research right there's this huge pool
for a physician scientist to go back
into the clinics
especially when it's difficult to get
research funding how can we promote them
to stay in research in the most
efficient and effective way and finally
last but certainly not least
postdoctoral training is something that
I'm very interested in finding ways that
we can improve and use more effectively
70% of Life Sciences PhDs and the u.s.
right now go on to do postdocs yet only
40% go on to actually run research
groups whether it be an industry or
academia is that the right balance so
what is postdoctoral training for and
who should be doing it if you're
spending five years as a postdoc getting
paid forty five thousand dollars a year
and then you're going to go on into a
you know non lab head career was that
the right choice or was there a huge
opportunity cost when you could have
entered that career directly and paid
more money started your career five
years earlier improving postdoctoral
training as a whole
I'd also like to think about right right
now most places the postdocs are just
working in the lab they're in and that's
pretty much it can we improve that
experience for them can we add more
value to them through some kind of
structured training or mentoring in
various ways and so I think that's a
very important and under thought about
group of researchers in a system and I
think we really owe it to the system and
to them to focus more on what's
happening in that space so the last
thing I'll say is just I've told you
about a lot of different things that
we're working on and I've totally bought
a lot of it from problems in the system
I hope I've convinced you that NIH is
taking this seriously and is really
willing to make significant changes and
try major new things but the fact is we
can make the biggest changes you can
imagine and theoretically the best but
if the rest of the system is not willing
to make reciprocal changes it will make
that much difference okay so this really
is a shared responsibility and I hope
that you will join us you'll communicate
with us in figuring out how we as a
enterprise can really write this boat
and you know get it sailing the way it
should be sailing again so thank you
very much and I'm sorry it took so much
time happiness a question
up there we have to up here okay the red
shirt thank you okay I'll repeat the
question since they're people other
cameras so the question is how does the
mirror the r35 mechanism interface with
funding from other institutes or private
foundations so we are just limiting the
funding to you know that's your NIGMS
grant we're not saying you can't have
others at least not at the moment
right this was a discussion I had with
other IC directors we do though however
have the $750,000 direct costs trigger
is what we call it so if an investigator
has 750,000 dollars or more in total
direct costs from any source we and our
council take a very close look at the
budgets of any grants we're going to
give them and take into account that
additional funding when making a funding
decision and when deciding how much to
give them so that will factor in and in
fact we will factor this in as we were
making funding decisions as a whole
since this is now your funding from
NIGMS if we have one grant to deal with
it's a lot easier than if there's three
others floating around out there from
NIGMS as well moving forward we'll have
to see how it evolves does that answer
your question yes so that's something
again the question is double funding so
someone gets an NCI grant and they're
Mira and are they working on the same
thing so that's again something we're
gonna have to monitor very closely at
the renewal stage and at the you know
yearly progress report stages are these
distinct enough if someone has an NCI
grant is that really about cancer or you
know is there something and there's a
gray area and I think we you know we
have to this is going to be a discussion
moving forward
thank you yes so the question is about
salary support so and you see it here
acutely we have the Dean of the medical
school sitting here you know at a
medical school like I was at Hopkins or
here faculty are frequently asked to
raise 70 or even up to 100 percent of
their salaries off of grants that's the
system that we built up over the years
whereas it in arts and sciences campus
it may be the inverse you may only have
to raise 30 percent your summer salary
one one thing I didn't mention is that
one of the requirements of mirror is
that you put 51% research effort on the
grant 51% that's research episode
doesn't include clinical time it doesn't
teaching time it doesn't include
administrative time that helps us with
partly with this issue just because it
means that we're not penalizing someone
in arts and sciences campus who is
getting a hard salary by saying you know
you can't take as much effort or etc.the
you know the overall question though
what are we going to do about this
salary support issue is a harder one
it's when I've been discussing with
various leaders and the community I
discussed it with a double-a FC recently
it's something we have to wrestle with
if you want to write that boat and make
it sustainable pulling the plug
immediately I think would be
catastrophic but moving towards some
more sustainable mechanism finding ways
that NIH can support other things
whether it be research resources core
facilities helping with startup packages
in exchange for the institution's taking
long term commitments the salary
supports I think there are models that
we can work with it I really hope we can
engage more with the you know all of you
and with the academic leaders to find
those solutions because we have to
oh there's two more up here right so
with the questions what's this metric of
success for the mirror pilot and how
soon can it be implemented so I'll take
the last first we've started
implementing it already so we're about
you were taking applications now for
that established investigator cohort
we're writing the one for the new
investigator and so hopefully that will
be out in the early summer and then
we'll see how that goes and so that cuts
your first part of the question which is
success there are lots of different
metrics we are developing to measure
success so some of them are things like
I showed you like publications comparing
the mirror investigators to the you know
people doing the old ro1 system I admit
that's you know publications is just one
thing it's flawed in various ways but if
you saw a big change and one you know
one group relative the other would tell
you something that you wanted to explore
more citations being the same at cetera
my guess is if we give people more
freedom an extra year the average person
gets a little bit more money we're not
going to see a decrease in those things
to me more the success we have to look
at immediately is can we get more for
the money we have can we support more
investigators with this can we get a
more diverse portfolio of research and
investigators from this as opposed to
the opposite right so failure would be
if for some reason we ended up with a
very small cohort getting you know most
of the money and we'd actually shrunk
our pool investigators and reduce the
diversity of our portfolio so those are
some of the kinds of things we're
looking at if it starts to work we're
going to expand it as fast as we can
yes it the question is the mirror
mechanism being considered at other
Institute's yes there's been a lot of
interest from other Institute's I've
spoken at almost ten councils of other
Institute's now about this
usually the and almost all of them the
response from the council has been very
positive
ni NDS right now is writing something
similar it's actually very much based on
ours it's gonna have some tweaks and
differences I think if it does come out
but it's the same idea NCI has an
outstanding investigator award which has
some with similarities but is actually
in some substantial ways different so
how much money is going into it so
established investigators it's easy
because they are already there and so
all we're doing at some level is taking
one kind of research grant and changing
it into another okay and so at worst
it'll be a zero sum but we're actually
going to shave as I said some money out
of it and put it back into the system so
it's cost at worst neutral the new
investigators what we have to do is
figure out how many we want to fund and
part of what we're doing is looking
historically how many do we fund each
year and then try to decide is that the
right number to start out with or not
and that would be the maximum that could
come in because for them any new
investigator if you come into that who's
doing work relevant to NIGMS again
though if they get that they're not
gonna get an ro1 so it's not it's not a
set-aside in the same way that if I say
I'm going to put a set-aside in to
transcription and give it to them that
would be a suicide
yeah yep
absolutely so the questions about
instrumentation and the you know the
cost of instrumentation keeps going up
and keeping the us at the cutting edge
requires you know continual investment
and support so I didn't have time to
talk about this but another effort
that's going on right now at NIGMS is
trying to optimize our support for both
technology development and access to
research resources okay and understand
how to couple those two things and wind
a couple of those do you think so that's
something that will be coming out in the
next year I think two things I will note
about that is one there's a lot of
opportunity for improving the efficiency
and creating economies of scale right so
if we can provide say regional resources
or if we can help universities set up
more efficient core facilities I think
researchers could get a lot more out of
you know the same amount of money
universities could save money we could
probably stretch our dollars more so
that needs to be thought about again in
partnership cryo-em I've had a lot of
discussions with I'll just say we are
absolutely committed and I GMS and the
discussions now going on nih-wide to
finding the best way to provide access
to these amazing new cryo-em tools that
are coming and to promoting their
continued development it's a question of
the most efficient way to do that so
we'll continue these discussions with
the community
oh thank you
thank you all thanks a lot of fun